So the prophet when dictated letters we
are Muslim. So the prophet was a Muslim.
All these great scholars all these four
immas and the other scholars Imam Abu
Hanifh, Imam Malik, Imam Shafi, Imam
Ahmed Hal, they were great scholars. May
Allah have mercy on them all.
They were great scholars. We should love
them. We should respect them.
If you ask
Imam Malik, what was he?
What will he tell you? Muslim. If you
ask Imm Shafi, will he say I'm a Shafi?
I'm Muslim. All were Muslims. All the
four they said if you find any of my
fatwa which goes against the Quran or
any say of the prophet throw my fatwa on
the wall. So we love these.
WE RESPECT THEM. BUT BECAUSE OF THEM, WE
DON'T FIGHT AMONGST OURSELVES. We
Muslims, we learn Islam through them. WE
LOVE THEM. WE RESPECT THEM. BUT BECAUSE
OF THAT, WE DON'T FIGHT AMONGST
OURSELVES. NOW, MANY MUSLIMS said only I
will go to Jenna. Our beloved prophet
Muhammad sallallahu alaihi wasallam said
it's mentioned had of sunahud had number
6 that in my ummah there will be 73
sects there's another say had ofdi had
number 2641
in which the prophet said my ummah will
be divided into 73 sects and only one
will go to jenna. The prophet said my
ummah will be divided. Prophet did not
say divide. Allah said don't make sex.
Allah say those who make sex have
nothing to do with him. But prophet is
predicting.
The prophet said in the Jews there were
71 sects. In the nasara Christian 72
sect in my um there will be 70. He
didn't say should make out of that only
one will go to Jenna. Which one? The
prophet said those who follow me and my
sahabas, those who follow the jama.
So all these ayas, they are giving us
different interpretation. THEY ARE
HELPING US UNDERSTAND ISLAM. They never
came to divide all these great ayah.
They respected each other. They never
fought with today. They are fighting
amongst ourselves. Why? Only I will go
to Jenna.
Why? So in Islam there is no sect in
Islam. Islam is only one. Those who make
sex Allah says they have nothing to do
with him. And only one sect will go to
Jenna. Those that follow the prophet and
the Sabas. When she also
what is mentioned in the Quran only two
either Muslim or Abdullah. When
was asked if someone calls himself
tabliki or jamati is it correct? He said
calling yourself tabliki OR JAMATI OR
SALAFI IS WRONG. Following salaf is a
fur but calling yourself salafi or
jamati or tablik is wrong.
If someone calls themselves deopandi
because he's passed from I've got no
objection. Someone calls himself madni
because he's passed from Islamic mad I
have got no problem. But as an identity
of a religion all in Muslim mean say
that I am a Muslim. Islam believes in
uniting the um not dividing. So it's a
misconception
that there are sex in Islam. Islam does
not believe in having sex. We should
follow Allah and his Allah says inah
4:59
obey Allah and obey the messengers and
those
who have the authority but if the people
with authority differ Allah continues
follow Allah and his rasool go back to
Allah and his rasool so if we Muslims
read the Quran with understanding and we
read the hadith of the prophet with
understanding no one will take you for a
ride if you have difficulties go to an
alim
Ask him but don't create division. So in
Islam the ummah is only one.